on the outskirts of kiev reservists
practice how to protect their city from
a russian invasion
in the field
in the classroom
even in the air
this weekend training could be tested
for real if international efforts this
week to stop a wider war in ukraine fail
it's a threat that's prompted a rise in
civilians signing up to serve from
this student is so keen he even bought
most of his own kit it's american lvt
with armor plates from ukrainian brand
this is all the stuff i needed he wants
to protect his identity just giving his
military call sign jaeger
if you have to fight will you fight yes
yes i would
and we are getting ready we are getting
prepared we are training say no to putin
say no to putin say no to putin defiance
on the streets as well
western powers urged not to strike a
compromise deal with russian president
vladimir putin who's masked tens of
thousands of troops at their border i'm
worried about the threat which is
ukraine is under now so we we are all
afraid that we will be attacked by
russia
ukrainians want to make sure their voice
is heard during a crucial week of
diplomacy over the fate of their country
and wider security in europe but western
diplomats privately question whether
talks between russia the united states
and other nato allies will succeed with
the head of nato even warning that the
risk of new conflict is real
[Music]
this country is no stranger to war ever
since russia annexed crimea in 2014 and
backed separatists in the east
[Music]
their war dead remembered daily
[Music]
a toll that's still growing and could
rise sharply if hostilities explode once
more
debra haynes sky news kiev